the trans do you know I mean the the
weak men they don't want to have kids
anymore that the feminists are like we
don't need men is it by accident or is
it an effort to really slow down the the
population like is it is it a deeper
thing I think America's at War I think
America is at War I think that people
always thought World War III would be
something like World War II people would
be dropping nukes and no I think it's
it's a silent War it's an ideological
war
um I believe that there is a globalized
effort to take down America from within
and people realizing after years China
is a huge part of this effort that you
could take over America without firing a
single single bullet it begins and ends
with culture and that's why I believe
that culture is the biggest battle that
we're facing right now